OK.
So earlier on on in the show, I told you about
the claims that John Bolton makes in his book.
Donald Trump okaying Chinese concentration
camps.
Trump saying invading Venezuela would be cool.
Trump asking China for help getting reelected.
Trump saying reporters should be imprisoned
or executed.
Trump didn't know that the UK had nuclear
weapons.
On and on and on.
We did that earlier in the show.
I then told you about the legal battle by
Trump's Justice Department to suppress the
publication of John Bolton's book, including
a footnote provision that is asking courts
to ban bookstores from selling Bolton's book
under threat of punishment or legal action.
So we already did all of that stuff.
Now I want to talk about Donald Trump's reaction.
Donald Trump, predictably, was so triggered
by what is in John Bolton's book that he absolutely
exploded both on television and on Twitter.
It's been going for almost 24 hours now.
We just had to add more tweets to this story
because Trump just won't stop tweeting.
So here is Trump kicking it off last night
with Sean Hannity, Fox News propagandist,
total total disinformation, whitewashing attempt
of the entire story, calling Bolton a washed
up criminal.
Let's take a look at this clip.
And then in terms of Bolton, he broke the
law.
He was a wash up guy.
I gave him a chance.
He couldn't get Senate confirmed.
So I gave him a non Senate confirmed position.
And I could just put him there, see how we
worked.
And I wasn't very enamored.
He went into the Middle East.
He was one of the big guns for let's go into
Iraq.
And that didn't work out too well.
And I was against that a long time ago before
I was ever even thinking about doing what
I'm doing now.
But he was one of the people wanted to go
direct.
When I asked him about it, I said recently,
I said, you know, about a month in and when
he was about a month in, I said, What do you
think?
You think you've made a mistake there?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think so.
Said, explain that one.
So the terrible, terrible thing that he did.
But he broke the law.
Very simple.
I mean, as much as it's going to be broken,
this is highly classified.
That's why I say it's highly classified information
that he did not have approval.
So this is this is amazing.
Trump says both that Bolton's claims are lies
and that they're classified if they're lies.
How are they classified?
It's made up stuff.
Right.
It just doesn't make any sense.
And Trump's also funny because he says Bolton
was bad because he went into Iraq and Trump
hired him 15 years later.
Knowing that, doesn't Trump say he hires the
best people?
So Trump making no sense.
If it's lies, how are they classified?
If you hire the best people, why did you hire
someone that is so terrible?
And then the real triggering Trump clearly
sitting there fermenting with his phone tweet
after embarrassing tweet.
And I want to look at a couple of these with
you.
Donald Trump retweeting right wing disinformation,
propagator Dinesh D'Souza, who attacked Bolton,
Donald Trump adding to de Sousa's tweet.
President Bush fired him.
Also, Bolton is incompetent.
Trump calling Bolton a wacko and a dope, tweeting,
quote, wacko.
But John Bolton's exceedingly tedious book
is made up of lies and fake stories said all
good about me in print until the day I fired
him.
A disgruntled, boring fool who only wanted
to go to war, never had a clue, was ostracized
and happily dumped.
What a dope.
And I go back again if their lies.
How is it a problem that Bolton is publishing
classified information?
If he's making it all up, it by definition
couldn't be classified because it doesn't
really exist.
Right.
Trump kept going this morning completely out
of control, saying, quote, Bolton's book,
which is getting terrible reviews, is a compilation
of lies and made up stories all intended to
make me look bad.
Many of the ridiculous statements he attributes
to me were never made pure fiction, just trying
to get even for firing him like the sick puppy
he is.
And again, if it's all lies, why are you suppressing
it on the basis of it being classified?
And then a two series, two tweet series where
he says, quote, When wacko John Bolton went
on deface the nation and so stupidly said
that he looked at the Libyan model for North
Korea.
All hell broke out.
Kim Jong un, who we were getting along with
very well, went ballistic.
Just like his missiles and rightfully so.
He didn't want Bolton anywhere near him.
Bolton's dumbest of all statements set us
back very badly with North.
Maria, even now, I asked him, what the hell
were you thinking?
He had no answer and just apologize.
That was early on.
I should have fired him right then and there
now.
Now, we could do an hour on Trump with North
Korea and his delusions.
The real problem with North Korea was Trump
falling for the same stuff that North Korean
leaders have been doing and saying for 30
years.
Trump actually believed it, right.
Other presidents, both Democrat and Democratic
and Republican, knew that they shouldn't fall
for the idiotic and unbelievable claims from
North Korean leaders.
Trump fell for them, so Trump thought he was
making progress.
So, I mean, I don't even know where where
to start all of this.
Right.
FOX His position has been to get experts on
saying Bolton's book endangers our national
security by putting out classified and secret
information.
Well, Trump says it's all lies.
So how can lies be secret and classified at
the same time?
The real risk to our national security all
along has been Donald Trump.
Remember, Trump once tweeted what should have
been a classified and remained classified
satellite photo.
National security means nothing to Trump.
Trump once had a meeting with Russians in
the Oval Office and shared Israeli intelligence
with them, which he had not been given the
OK to share, which endangered an actual important
source of information about ISIS, for example,
which Donald Trump claimed to be fighting
very, very strongly about.
So if you want to talk about endangering national
security and playing fast and loose with what
should be secret and classified information,
and I say should because I understand legally
Trump can declassify whatever he wants, doesn't
mean it's smart or prudent to do it.
Really, it's Trump we need to be looking at.
And again, I have a tweet about this, which
you can look at the Pacman on Twitter.
How is it that Trump is furious that Bolton
is both lying, but that what he writes in
the book is classified information?
If they are lies, it doesn't exist.
It's made up.
And therefore, being classified wouldn't actually
be a problem.
I'm sure that the Trumps will find some way
to excuse that completely incoherent claim,
but it is not making too much sense.
Now, let's dig again.
I've been building to this.
Bolton deserves huge criticism for what he
did to some degree, and that's where we're
going to go next